hey guys Ryan right over here Dan
Seibert over on this side of the couch
dan is a fan of this game called no man
Scott goddamn right I am so I mean to
check out this game I am getting my ps4
soon I'm going to catch up on video
games starting with ps4 games and yes
three so no man's sky gameplay demo
released at e3 2015 Dan get ready to
jizz get ready my body is ready hi guys
so last year the studio's we showed you
a video of this crazy game we're making
corner and sky this year I guess I
really just wanted to show you how to
place
whoa
Star Tours making a universe sandbox
choices oh wow space travel at the
boundary between two warring factions I
could join in I can take sides
see that old school yeah but first
personal I dig it that's a tiny glimpse
of space combat but I've only got three
better today's loads I want to show you
like this so this is the solar system
that were currently at that's where that
battle is taking place but battles like
that are taking place across the
universe
thanks face facts you could see the
other stars nearby that I can reach with
my turn hyperdrive and I'm going to pull
back a little bit Lord to give you a
sense of the size of the game what do I
really need you to keep in mind to
understand that every one of these
points of light is a Sun every one of
those sons has its own solar system with
planet sized planets orbiting around it
wow those have life ecology
oh my god oh we're like open universe
season most of these places I've never
been visited many of them never will be
that's bold over there in the distance
is a center in the galaxy that's where
we're all trying to get to and I'm going
to do something really stupid
I'm just gonna pick one of these at
random we can go there now this one's
okay in rehearsal otherwise it would be
here but if anything horrible goes wrong
just keep in mind that I've not been
here before least he's honest
cool so here we are in an undiscovered
solar system probably no one's ever been
here before I could do a scan and when I
do you'll see some points of interest
that red one down there is a beacon
I've made it so that there's always a
peek in there where I warp in just for
this it's like an oculus experience I
know
oh my god this on the oculus
so beacons are where you
beacons oh where you upload discoveries
that's it over there beyond that Brock
and it's the planet that we've just
found just an alien world that we found
together this is one of III ah I will
succeed a lot worse all right so I keep
doing scan and it's like whatever
there's no alien life but I can show you
this so every planet in every solar
system is fully destructible yeah that
red one it
oh wow oh [ __ ]
those guys are the Sentinels they
protect the planets from explorers like
me
hey I'm underwater and this fish is a
fish so now I need to find that beaker
and I can upload those discoveries
so now when the game is a Houten will
announce release date soon I promise and
the game is out on a game like one day
come across this planet let's just a
little glimpse of no man's sky its
trading biding exploring survival and
it's a huge game that's one big yeah how
were they gonna find the server space to
run all of this imagine playing that
game online it is gonna be on look
that's [ __ ] and I know just and it's
gonna be [ __ ] insane ridiculous holy
they've they're taking open world to a
whole new experience well it's like even
if they have even if you get a million
people this will probably sound like
what like maybe two million copies if it
does insanely well you have two million
people and then you look at all of those
stars that you panned out to and there's
absolutely no way that two million
people are gonna explore all that yeah
that is what that is what he said how
many planets are there like each of
those stars could have had like three to
six plans
yeah because he said we're looking at
the sons of them this is X that's insane
I mean the graphics I mean this game
still in development so I'm sure the
graphics will be better they're just
really stylized is the thing that's like
bright colors and I mean like maybe some
of the animation becomes smoother but
it's getting close yeah because it still
looks like early development graphics
but the graphics still look pretty
decent I mean just the exploration is
it's kind of hard to like wrap your
whole mind around cuz there's so much to
do alright so easy and like that planet
like you walk around that entire planet
yeah yeah exactly
but what is it what's the like the point
of the game like just to explore do you
like have missions or well he's you did
talk about the fact that we're all
trying to get to the center of the
galaxy so I imagine it's get a warp
drive I mean for you that have played
sport when you get to Space Age stage
you're you get like a certain you get an
engine and you can upgrade that engine
to go further and further but the
objective is to get all the way to the
center of the universe okay
and it seems like it's gonna be similar
to that with the idea of is like you buy
a ship it can only go so far you go and
you explore and each time you explore
something you get a little more
cash and then battles and a lot sort of
stuff and you're just trying to upgrade
your [ __ ] to get to the center of the
universe I mean that's just my
speculation on what you're gonna try to
do in the game yeah because they were
saying like the planets of sentinels
that are there to take out explorers
like yourself so it's kind of sound like
your antihero in some ways possibly or
there could be like some evil magic
bad tech people the universe [ __ ] them
right that's just not realistic now it's
just kind of a little overwhelming
because there's so much like when they
were showing you like here's all the
planets you can explore I was like how
will I choose where he's going up how
will how will I determine where I want
to go exactly I wonder how this game
will actually perform if it will live up
to the hype I'm what I'm really
interested to see personally is like I
pick up the game you pick up the game a
couple of us you know pick up the game
it's like we start off on a random
planet how the [ __ ] are we gonna find
out the other guy it just is so
ambitious this is exactly kind of what
the gaming industry needs is something
like really ambitious saying like yo
this is what next-gen about it's not
about really sharp graphics yes we have
that but it's about we can the scope of
the game that we can make now is massive
yeah there are no limits to what we can
do or at least it certainly seems like
we're pushing that it's like when Ultron
hacks into the [ __ ] computer system
of everything in the world you feel like
you're just get actually no that's kind
of crazy I'm having a hard time wrapping
my brain around because that was [ __ ]
insane I'm I could not be more excited
to like actually get my hands on the
game and try it like did you just yeah
you did yeah yeah did and yeah you my
mind did anyway guys thanks for tuning
in to the real rejects if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you get you go dansgaming
channel that cyber channel do it you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
and vine where if we get enough
followers we could get even more
placement more money Kevin Lim hi shout
out please I'm from your Carta Indonesia
Indonesian you must have seen the raid
I'm a really big fan of your work those
reactions and reviews are great thank
you it has been a year since I watch
your videos every day and it always
makes me laugh Veronica she's beautiful
I know I know she's so hot look I love
holding hands with her she doesn't let
me do anything beyond that don't stop
making videos and keep the dick jokes
rolling I would make a dick joke but
Veronica is sitting right over there and
she gets uncomfortable with my dick
jokes especially when the dick jokes are
about her like how she never looks on my
show it was cool to talk about me
[ __ ] but you can't make a dick joke
not about me with Veronica there I mean
ELISA is here so I can make a dick joke
about you and ELISA does she laugh and
point the way how Veronica laughs and
point in mine no seemed like a personal
problem
Veronica's always like mm-hmm you have
an Indonesian penis Oh God
Kevin Lim I know what it's like to have
a small penis I've been there with you
buddy all Indonesians have small penises
and so do i why do people ask for shout
I don't know all I do isn't so good